non je vais revenir sur juste différent
de notre histoire les foils avait été
incarcéré 29 mois suite à une erreur
judiciaire qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comme vous l'avez dit mon histoire et
les folles mais les réelles et beaucoup
de personnes malheureusement ont vécu ce
que moi j'ai vécu en 2007 ya la même
usine qui ont été percutés par une
voiture de police à la suite de ça il ya
eu des événements dramatiques
on peut appeler ça comme on veut émeutes
soulèvement populaire révolte et cetera
peu importe des policiers qui sont fait
tirer dessus et penser qu'ils sont fait
tabasser
il a eu la ville qui a été mis à feu et
à sang à la suite de ça il ya eu une
grosse vague politique et médiatique qui
a été déversé sur villiers-le-bel et
nicolas sarkozy tous tous tout son
gouvernement qui qui ont mis on va dire
alors là leurs mains dans tout ça et du
coup ça adonné à des grosses
arrestations et à des grosses dois dire
délation parce qu'ils ont proposé de
l'argent aux différents témoins qui
pourraient apporter
comment dire ça qui pourrait apporter un
début de réponse pour avoir les tireurs
et vous vous avez été dénoncés j'ai été
dénoncée d'une certaine façon et cette
fonction-là dont j'ai été dénoncée c'est
c'est lâche c'est hypocrite et c'est
juste plus humain il ya eu une grosse
vague d'interpellations cette vague
d'interpellations il ya eu à peu près
une trentaine de personnes qui ont été
placées en garde à vue et à la suite de
ces gardes à vue là moi je n'avais pas
de casier judiciaire âgés parfois de
garde à vue j'ai j'avais même pas le
lait les seules choses que j'ai vécues
ces des contrôles au faciès mais sinon
j'ai pas eu de rapport direct avec la
police bon du coup moi qui prétendait
tranquillement une carte de footballeur
professionnel
quand il a eu ses effets qui sont
arrivés en 2007
laramée nous est décédé 11 il va y avoir
une justice a pas de justice on a
incriminé par les médias on a incriminé
par les politiques
qu'est ce qui se passe à un moment donné
ça part dans tous les sens il ya les
interpellations les interpellations à
son fait d'une façon très douteuse et on
est placé directement en garde à vue
quand moi je suis placé en garde à vue
je clame l'innocence du début jusqu'à la
fin on entend pas on m'écoute pas 24
heures 48 heures 80 72 heures 96 eur et
la suite de ces 96 heures en place ou en
détention et après après m'avoir
mis en détention on met sous un régime
particulier qui s'appelle l' isolement
donc on passe en isolement moi je me dis
que je suis innocent j'ai rien fait et
on met dans des conditions comme ça dans
la france et passe à la gestion par mois
soit avant là j'ai fait 29 mois de
détention
mais durant ses 29 mois c'est que j'ai
été oppressés durant les 29 mois j'ai
été séquestré durant les 29 mois et j'ai
été brutalisé dans mon for intérieur et
jeudi violée dans mon for intérieur
comment les 29 mois pourquoi parce que
j'étais innocent j'avais 20 ans tu
prétends d'un quart de footballeur à
l'époque et au final je me retrouve dans
cette situation dramatique accusé à tort
avec briser des familles brisées des
frères et soeurs qui sont incroyables
maintenant brisé et en plus de ça on a
deux morts la ram usines se plient sous
terre et a pas de justice quand je n'y a
pas de justice
la famille à la réclamer la justice en a
aucune justice les policiers quelques
années après ils ont été condamnés ils
ont été condamnés pour une seule chose
un déni des vitesses ils n'ont pas été
condamnées parce que la ram une usine on
était décédée ont été condamnés juste
parce qu'ils avaient il ya eu un délit
de de deux vitesses
donc à partir d'ici innocenté ou pas du
tout viatique moi je n'ai passé 29 -
détention après les 29 ans il ya eu un
procès qui a duré
dans un premier temps dix jours aux
assises à pontoise à l'issue de ce
procès là le procureur lui demande 20
ans compte de mes co accusés 15 ans
quentin mais mes co accusés et moi même
et au final un des co-accusés qui écope
15 ans à bout il a souffert à damas
pareil il est comme tous les ans il a
souffert des délais cop 9 ans il a
souffert - j'écope au lieu de 15 on met
nu trois en trois ans on retient ici les
faits je suis accusée de au début de
tentative de meurtre à la suite de ça je
sais pas comment est ce que ça arrive et
on ne m'acquitte des faits qui me sont
reprochés mais on me condamne pour port
d'armes et on a vu que tout inquiète
tout l'inquiète qui a été mené elle a
été menée à la va vite et vous avez une
arme ou pas du tout j'y arrive quand tu
calcules osé faire la va vite on néglige
plein de choses mais toutes les choses
qui ont été négligés
on aurait pu faire ans en aurait pu
faire en sorte que
- meco accusant puisse sortir de ça et
ça n'a pas été fait donc la justice à la
fermer les yeux ça a été juste un
rouleau compresseur pour répondre à une
attente politique et ne vous enfermez
une condamnée et faire en sorte que
l'opinion publique sache que une fois
que les policiers sont à tirer dessus il
ya il ya direct le résultat et le
résultat il a été mauvais moi j'ai été
acquitté mais condamné pour port d'armes
je reconnaissais pas ces faits mais
croit accusés ont été condamnés la
ramène usine décédé et comprenait bien
qu'ils aient un impact et l'impact qui a
après ça c'est que il ya des répressions
c'est que la police fait tirer dessus et
en même temps dans la ville la police
elle elle occupe l'endroit est de plus
en plus moi mes frères mes soeurs mes
amis tout mon entourage noviny ces tests
est venu c'était devenu une zone de non
droit donc à un moment donné il ya des
questions à se poser
la justice ça va dans quel sens et pour
qui on donne la justice et pour qui on
donne la justice et maintenant je veux
revenir sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous parler d'engagement
politique mon engagement politique et
les pourquoi l'année dernière j'ai perdu
un ami qui s'appelle niveau ibrahima bah
il a été percuté par une voiture de
police
on n'a pas la réponse il ya des vidéos
sur les lieux de l'accident il ya des
vidéos on n'a pas les vidéos me demande
les vidéos et on les obtient de rabat et
quand bien même les autres on les
accueillera pas on va se battre pour les
obtenir
mais à un moment donné la justice à deux
pour tout le monde est là dans ces cas
là ya pas de justice pour je finis bruit
pour y boire n'y a pas de justice
pour adama et a pas de justice pour gain
camara ya pas de justice pour la mine
zhang a pas de justice pour sabri ya pas
de justice pour daf da vient pas de
justice et des noms je pourrais en citer
encore pleins ça c'est notre rêve et
réalité était sur la
[Applaudissements]